welcome back to CBS this morning we
begin with this there was new fallout in
Iran after the US drone strike that
killed a top Iranian general police say
millions of people poured into the
streets of Iran's capital this morning
for a funeral for general Kassim
soleimani Iran's supreme leader was seen
crying as he stood over the casket his
foreign minister tweeted photos of the
crowd and taunted President Trump
writing this do you still imagine you
can break the will of this great nation
and its people with Iran threatening
revenge attacks more than 3000
additional American soldiers are headed
to the Middle East but Iraq s--
Parliament wants to remove all US troops
from that country Elizabeth Palmer has
the latest from Tehran
good morning Iran has said it's not a
question of if it will respond but when
and how Iranian lawmakers chanted the by
now familiar death to America
after the Iranian government announced
it will all but pull out of the nuclear
deal it signed in 2015 and go back to
enriching as much uranium as it chooses
meanwhile Qasem Soleimani x' replacement
as head of the elite hoods force has
been named hes Esmail Ghani and he has
repeated the threat of reprisals against
the United States next door in Iraq
where Soleimani was killed by a US
missile there's also huge anger over the
assassination the parliament has voted
to expel the approximately 5,000
American troops currently stationed
there President Trump has responded to
both Iraq and Iran he's threatened to
bomb 52 Iranian sites including ones of
cultural significance an action that
experts and diplomats warn could be
considered a war crime back in the
United States Speaker Nancy Pelosi says
the house will vote to limit president
Trump's actions toward Iran she argues
that he overstepped his power by acting
without congressional approval
Tony Elizabeth Palmer and Tehran
Elizabeth thank you very much now Iran
is a top-ten global threat according to
a new annual report examining the
dangers the world faces but for the
first time a US domestic
ooh tops the list it's the annual
ranking of the top ten geopolitical
risks from the Eurasia group a
consulting firm and the list can set
concerns about America outrank worries
over Iran Turkey and Latin America Ian
Bremmer is president and founder of the
Eurasia Group ne joins us now in good
morning I want to get to your concerns
about what's happening in this country
but first with Iran you say that war is
not a likely outcome that's a lonely
opinion at the moment walk us through it
and my new year's resolutions try to
talk people away from look people are
saying the Trump's trying to wag the dog
here right if he wanted war against Iran
he has had ample opportunity to show the
Iranians that when they were taking and
hitting tankers in the Straits of Hormuz
or when they engaged in strikes against
Saudi Arabia taking 50% to the oil off
the markets Trump didn't do anything
yeah and indeed the Saudis decided they
need to negotiate with Iranians the
consequence of that so what happened is
the Iranians have continued to escalate
in response to the u.s. pulling out of
the nuclear deal and finally they hit
America's and Trump's response to them
hitting Americans was escalatory was
dramatically escalatory and if mattis
and others have been around maybe they
could have contained them a little bit
so there's a cycle of violence here as
you know be spinning up I mean how do
you see it spinning the other how do you
see it calming down don't they have to
do something yeah they have to do
something but we have to do something
the administration didn't believe that
the Americans were going to hit them
like this when they went after our
embassy when they went after our
soldiers on that base in northern Iraq
now they do
they get it and you know what if you're
the world's largest military power you
can miscalculate more I mean I hate to
say that yeah but it's a reality the
Iranians completely understand that now
if they hit a bunch of Americans they
were still regime it's a massive power
imbalance you're saying you said he's
not trying to wag the dog what's he
doing I think he's petting the dog I
think yeah what it means is that to the
extent that Trump is trying to
accomplish really unusual and D
legitimize things in there on to the
election it's much more about giving the
store to American adversaries and
claiming a massive deal whether it's the
Russians and the Turks or the Chinese so
the North Koreans are unique
even the Iranians this was a guy that
wanted to have a phone call with the
Iranian president facilitated by the
French back at the United Nations
General Assembly to say hey let's get a
deal and he still would be willing to
engage in diplomacy right now and to be
fair the Iranians are hardly in the mood
for that after having you know sulemani
killed but Iran is weaker today than
they were when Trump became president
both economically because of the
sanctions but also militarily because of
what just happened to that important
leaders all right let's let's get to us
and the risk you see here you see a risk
in the election I do what's the risk
oh the risk is that no matter who wins
if it's close it's gonna be seen as
rigged it's going to be seen as
illegitimate we we have we we will now
have seen in a way that's really
unprecedented that impeachment doesn't
actually work to contain or constrain
against abuses of power of a sitting
president he's then running for
re-election when rigged in what way that
someone's using unfair tactics to
campaign or that the votes are not
counted properly how do you see those I
mean rigged in the sense that when Trump
is running after he is acquitted by the
Senate his ability to use and abuse the
powers of the executive to ensure that
he has a better shot of winning to not
defend the sanctity of elections against
external interference as the as
McConnell and Senators also not willing
to do if Trump wins the Democrats will
claim rigged
if Trump loses he's going to say I
didn't actually lose wasn't a fair
election that the risk of that is that
you're gonna have a period of weeks or
months where you're not actually sure
what you voted for you're not sure who
governs it's like kind of gore bush but
without the sudden outcome from Supreme
Court where legislature doesn't
necessarily work I mean we haven't had
that kind of an election the US since
1876 or the election of Ruth referred
Hayes where the election itself didn't
work the election was diligent amazed
and I think people don't understand that
running into 2020 it's not about World
War 3 but it's about a real question of
Americans of whether or not we're
governed can we go back to Iran for a
second because we said we know that
they're going to after retaliate Tony
said and then we're gonna have to
retaliate to that yeah and you didn't
respond what what what how
in Zoey and I find the whole thing so
frightening who steps back right well
Ron Ian's are already stepping back a
bit if you look at what the Foreign
Minister from Iran is said in the last
48 hours she's talking much more about
the Americans being forced to withdraw
from the region he's talking you know
about much more about those sorts of
things and about then then he is about
hitting American military sources
interesting the Trump initially said I'm
gonna hit 52 sides
more recently the tweet was the
escalating war recently the tweet was it
might be disproportionate might not I
mean look if there's anyone we know in
the United States that has the ability
to forget what he said the day before
and do what's convenient for him today
it's Donald Trump all right so I just
think we should not expect World War 3
in the near term all right I hope you're
right here you are - thank you
you